hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and with all the
recent craziness in the one piece story
including new yonkos the return of
shanks the introduction of green bull
and more one massive development hasn't
received nearly as much hype as it
deserves the major reveals about pluton
sleeping somewhere on wano and the
existence of old wano beneath the
surface of nuana are actually crucial
for deciphering the ending of one piece
this is the key piece of the puzzle
after which all the other pieces are
going to fall into place very quickly so
we need to talk about it before we get
into it a quick thank you to scentbird
for sponsoring this video scentbird is a
subscription service that allows both
men and women to choose from over 500
top designer and niche fragrances and
have them delivered directly to their
door i love fragrances but i don't wear
them every day so i'd pay like a hundred
bucks or more for a bottle of cologne
and then i'd be stuck with that bottle
for a very long time because let's be
real i'm not about to spend hundreds
more dollars on other bottles before i
even use up that one this is why
scentbird is perfect for me it allows me
to get multiple premium fragrances every
single month and only the amount that i
actually need without the high cost of
buying full bottles individually this
month i ordered eros by versace and uomo
by kavali because i'm classy but then i
realized that these are not exactly the
best fragrances for hot summer days
thankfully scentbird also sent me two
additional fragrances that i think are
much better for summer including well
played by confessions of a rebel and
layton by parfum de marle i love this
service and you should definitely check
it out for yourself just click that link
below and use my code animate 55 to get
55 off your first month at scentbird
that's only eight dollars for your first
month oh and scentbird is now available
in canada which is awesome because i'm
in canada so that worked out great click
the link in the description right now
finally this video will contain one
piece manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned pluton
is one of the three ancient weapons
along with poseidon and uranus and it
was first mentioned all the way back in
chapter 192
that's when crocodile asks king cobra
about pluton's location during the
alabasta arc and ever since that time
the entire one-piece fan base has been
wondering what exactly pluton is and
where it's located according to what
we've learned along the way especially
during the water 7 arc pluton is an
incredibly powerful and technologically
advanced battleship that can be turned
into a weapon of mass destruction pluton
is so powerful that several characters
in the story believed that getting their
hands on it would allow them to
practically rule over the entire world
and pluton is believed to be capable of
destroying entire islands with a single
attack now unlike poseidon which is a
power that is inherited by a specific
person pluton appears to be a physical
object more specifically it's supposed
to be a massive and overpowered
battleship and we know this because
blueprints for it actually exist
or they existed until frankie destroyed
them that said before he destroyed them
multiple experienced shipbuilders seemed
to confirm that these blueprints were
legit meaning that pluton really was a
battleship that can be physically built
using these blueprints in fact the
blueprints had been preserved for a very
specific purpose pluton is said to be so
powerful that if it ever fell into the
wrong hands someone would need to build
a rival pluton just to stand a chance
against the original and so the secret
blueprints were passed on from
generation to generation of legendary
shipbuilders on water 7 until they
ultimately made their way to frankie and
speaking of water 7 the original pluton
is said to have been built on water 7
during the void century it is likely
that pluton played a major role in the
war between the ancient kingdom and the
alliance that would eventually become
the world government and since the world
government is not currently in
possession of pluton it is safe to
assume that pluton was a weapon that was
used by the enemies of the world
government i.e joy boy and the ancient
kingdom in fact the world government's
fear of the ancient weapons is one of
the main reasons why they forbade all
study of the poneglyphs they know that
if these ancient weapons were ever to be
recommissioned they would pose an
existential threat to the entire world
government system and once the current
location of pluton was finally confirmed
in chapter
1055 of the manga things became even
more interesting the ancient weapon
pluton is currently in guano it is
apparently buried deep within mount fuji
and it has presumably been there for 800
years ever since the void century since
we know that bono was never a part of
the world government and since we know
that the kozuki clan created the
poneglyphs in the first place it is safe
to assume that pluton was created and
used by the ancient kingdom and after
joy boy and his comrades lost the war
they hid pluton away inside a kingdom
that was friendly to them frankly the
fact that pluton is on wano is probably
the main reason why wano was
deliberately isolated from the world for
so long opening its borders would mean
awakening pluton and that would make
both pluton and wano a target for the
world government and so wano remained
isolated and pluton remained asleep for
eight centuries and that's an
interesting choice of words isn't it
pluton is said to be asleep or resting
rather than inactive or turned off or
decommissioned if pluton really was just
an inanimate object without some sort of
life or will of its own why use a word
like asleep i'll get back to this point
in a little bit but first let's talk
about the fascinating nature of pluton's
secret resting place
in chapter 1055
robin in law follow sukiyaki kozuki into
a secret underground passage underneath
the palace which leads them deep beneath
the surface of wano the passage actually
takes them beneath the sea floor and on
the bottom they discover something
incredible wano itself is located right
there at the bottom of the sea but wait
didn't they just leave wano up on the
surface how could wano be up on the
surface and deep beneath the ocean at
the same time sukiyaki explains that
this wano on the sea floor is the old
wano from 800 years ago from the time of
the void century sukiyaki doesn't know
what exactly happened all those
centuries ago but it's clear that this
wano on the sea floor the old wano was
the original wano the original wano was
much larger and it was located much
deeper beneath mount fuji and mount fuji
itself is actually a lot bigger than it
appears but more than half of it is now
covered by the sea at some point around
800 years ago gigantic walls appeared
around wano and they formed a perfect
seal between wano and the outside world
eventually the rain water filled up
everything beneath the walls and old
wanna was buried deep beneath the water
so old wado was abandoned and a new
smaller wano was built on the side of
mount fuji at the point that the
mountain emerges from the sea pluton is
currently resting somewhere beneath the
foot of mount fuji but sukiyaki has
never actually seen it so he doesn't
know where exactly it is or what it
looks like sukiyaki does know one thing
though in order to retrieve pluton the
giant walls that surround wano have to
be destroyed this is what it means to
open wanos borders it means destroying
the country's natural defenses and
opening it up to all the many threats
posed by the outside world it also means
unleashing the ancient weapon pluton
upon the world which could be a good
thing if the weapon gets into the right
hands but it could also be a complete
disaster if it ever gets into the wrong
hands now odin clearly wanted to open
mono to the outside world and yet when
he returned to wano odin did not open
its borders assuming odin knew about
pluton because he did after all go to
laugh tale it seems clear that he could
have used pluton to defeat kaido but he
didn't do it i believe that the reason
why odin didn't activate pluton is
directly related to the reason why roger
believed that he was too early and that
he still had to wait for someone in
order for pluton to be properly used
poseidon had to be reborn and joy boy
had to return so that is why odin
allowed himself to be killed by kaido
and rochi instead of just using pluton
to destroy them both i'll get back to
poseidon joy boy and uranus in a little
bit but first let's talk about what
pluton actually is it seems clear to me
that pluton can only be one thing pluton
is nuana itself after the ancient
kingdom lost the war 800 years ago they
decided to protect pluton by placing it
on top of old wano and then sealing it
off from the outside world using those
gigantic walls pluton is not just any
battleship it is a gigantic island-sized
battleship that has been hiding in plain
sight this entire time this is why
everyone who actually saw the blueprint
was absolutely shocked at the sight of
them as experienced shipbuilders people
like frankie rob lucci and kaku knew
that these blueprints were real but they
couldn't believe that something of that
size and scale had actually been built
and that brings me back to the words
that were used to describe the current
state of pluton on wano pluton was said
to be asleep or resting rather than
being turned off or inactive or
decommissioned
this implies that while pluton is a
highly advanced battleship it may not be
an inanimate object pluton may actually
be an organic battleship a battleship
that was built on top of some sort of
gigantic mythical creature similarly to
zou being on top of zunesha pluton could
be a fortified battleship that was built
on the back of a giant turtle or whale
or some other mythical sea creature and
this sea creature is currently asleep on
top of old wano the creature's back is
currently being used to house nuano but
once the creature awakens the residents
of nuana will return to old wano and
pluton will be used to fight against the
world government and also to destroy the
red line but more on that later oda gets
many of his ideas directly from existing
mythology and there are myths throughout
the world about giant sea creatures that
are the size of islands or that may even
have actual islands on their backs i
believe that pluton will ultimately be
revealed to be just such a creature but
there is another possibility as well
i've always thought that one specific
part of one piece felt kind of random
and out of place with the rest of the
story mostly because it was never really
followed up on since water 7 and annie's
lobby i am talking about the cloud
bautermann which is a water spirit that
dwells inside ships and is essentially
the personification of a ship this
phenomenon occurs on ships that have
gained a form of consciousness as a
result of being particularly well loved
and cared for by their crews the cloud
balterman is thought to only be a legend
in the world of one piece but this
legend is confirmed to be true when the
going mary's claude bautermann reveals
itself at skypia and then also in water
7 and annie's lobby maybe this unique
phenomenon that played such a pivotal
role with the going mary will reappear
again with another battleship the
ancient battleship pluton if pluton is
not a battleship that lies on top of a
giant mythical creature then it could be
a battleship that has gained sentience
due to the manifestation of a
particularly strong cloud bouterman this
cloud balterman may be quote unquote
asleep for now but he will one day
awaken when the time is right let me
know what you guys think down in the
comments could pluton be located on the
back of a giant sea creature or could it
be controlled by a powerful cloud
bouterman now the reason why pluton has
been asleep all this time is almost
certainly related to the fact that the
return of poseidon and joyboy were
required in order for pluton to awaken
there was a meme going around social
media that showed zunesha using his
giant trunk to drain the water from wano
which is what ultimately reveals old
wano and awakens pluton this is of
course an excellent meme but there may
also be an important grain of truth to
it i think that pluton can only awaken
when certain conditions are met and that
is why roger and odin knew that it was
still too early to open the borders of
wano 20 years ago the other ancient
weapons poseidon and uranus may be
required to awaken pluton and the return
of joy boy is likely directly related to
all of this as well i made an entire
video in which i argued that uranus is
actually the nika devil fruit itself but
the fruit first needed to awaken in
order for uranus to activate if this
theory is true we now have poseidon
pluton and uranus all on the board with
only pluton still needing to awaken i
believe that either poseidon uranus
joyboy or both are ultimately required
to awaken pluton for example the sea
kings may need to play a role in tearing
down the walls of wano or the new joy
boy may need to command zunesha to do
something specific such as draining the
water around wano or something else
along these lines pluton's ultimate
awakening may even involve vivi the last
remaining member of the ancient
nefertari family in the past i made the
argument that the nefertari family was
allowed to remain in alabasta for an
important reason after all the other
royal families left for marijuana at the
end of the void century after all not
moving to marijuana was seen as a
betrayal by the celestial dragons so why
would the celestial dragons allow this
betrayal to go unpunished why wouldn't
they just destroy the nefertari family
and take control of alabasta for
themselves i always felt that the
nefertari family in particular possessed
secret knowledge about pluton that made
the world government hesitant to
challenge them out of fear that pluton
could be turned against them we know
that luffy himself doesn't really care
about pluton which is certainly in line
with his character but he may come to
regret not having pluton in his corner
when it comes time to take on the entire
world government in the final battle and
of course from a narrative perspective
it makes no sense for oda to mention
pluton so many times and make such a big
deal about it only to never show it in
the story i wouldn't be surprised if
pluton is eventually retrieved not by
luffy but by vivi sabo and possibly
shirahoshi just in time for the final
battle and all of them will then meet up
with luffy and the straw hats on the
final battlefield whatever happens i am
confident that pluton will be awakened
and that it will play some major role in
the epic conclusion of the one piece
story it is only a matter of time if you
want to find out how i think everything
will end and why i think the recent
reveals about plutons kind of spoiled
the ending of one piece you were about
to find out i believe that all three
ancient weapons will play an essential
role in the final battle against the
world government and that the three of
them coming together in one piece will
be the key to everything the sea kings
pluton and uranus which i believe could
be nika itself will converge on the red
line a final epic battle will ensue the
red line will be destroyed and this will
create the all blue and so the three
ancient weapons coming together in one
piece is the very thing that will allow
the entire world to finally come
together in one piece as well there is a
reason why the poneglyphs contain
important information about the ancient
weapons
those who created the poneglyphs had
limited space and they used it to leave
only the most important messages to the
future generations and yet they chose to
spend a lot of space focusing on the
three ancient weapons that is not a
coincidence it is because the ancient
weapons will turn out to be
indispensable in the fight against the
world government and this will become
more and more clear as the final saga
unfolds
even if luffy leaves wano without
awakening pluton because he doesn't care
about it someone will definitely awaken
it before the final battle someone like
sabo vivi shirahoshi dragon or all of
them together and when that happens
pluton and poseidon will make their way
to the site of the final battle where
luffy and the straw hats will also be
waiting uranus will be there as well
either in the form of the nika devil
fruit or in whatever form it turns out
to be in and this is how one piece will
end the red line will be destroyed or at
least the part of it around marijua the
fishman will evacuate to the surface
inside the noaa the world will be united
in one piece and a giant party will
ensue across the entire
all blue this is my prediction and be
sure to share your own predictions for
how one piece will end down in the
comments oda has already confirmed that
this is the final saga the end really is
near so now is the best time to talk
about the ending and theorize about it
down in the comments below then when the
series finally does come to an end we
can come back to this video check the
comments and see if any of us were right
if you guys enjoyed this video you know
what to do leave a quick like and
comment it only takes a second but it
helps a lot with that youtube algorithm
and of course if you haven't already
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications it is a completely free
but very very important way of directly
supporting the channel you can also hit
me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror thanks again to scentbird for
sponsoring this video check them out
link in the description as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya space cowboys